a helium-filled blimp stays aloft since
helium is less dense than regular air so
helium will rise above regular air that
was a strangely phrased first sentence
but they're just saying helium is less
dense so helium will rise relative to
regular air the density of helium is
about 1.1 kilograms per meter cubed less
than regular air which means a cubic
meter of helium can lift about 1.1
kilograms because it has because the
density of helium so forget 4 cubic
meter of helium so this is a cubic meter
of helium so this is a cubic meter of
helium and here is a cubic meter of
regular air they're saying they're
saying that the mass of this cubic meter
of helium is going to be 1.1 kilograms
less than the mass of this cubic meter
of regular air and that's what allows it
because of the buoyancy that what that's
what allows a cubic meter of helium that
be able to lift about 1.1 kilograms a
blimp with the mass of 2.1 one times 10
to the 5th kilograms can carry as much
as as much as two times 10 to the 5th
cubic meters of helium if the average
mass of a person with luggage is 10 to
the 2nd kilograms what is the number of
passengers the blimp couldn't carry so I
encourage you to pause this video and
I'll give you a little structure for
this think about how much mass 2 times
10 to the 5th meter cubic meters of
helium can carry and then just realize
it has to carry the blimp and then
what's left over is what's what we can
use to carry people so I'm assuming
you've given a go at it so the first
step is to say look we have 2 times 10
to the 5th cubic meters of helium and
helium he a cubic meter of helium can
lift one point one killer one point one
kilograms so we could say
that we can lift we can lift 1.1
kilograms per cubic metre per cubic
metre so what is this going to give us
well our units cancel nicely this gives
us the number the the mass of kilograms
that we can lift meters cubes cancelling
with meters cube you'd have a meter
cubed in the numerator meter cubed in
the denominator our dimensional analysis
allows our units to cancel just like
numbers would in fractions and so we're
left with 2 times 10 to the fifth times
1.1 well 2 times 1.1 is 2 point 2 so
this is going to give us 2.2 times 10 to
the 5th kilograms is how much we can
lift so this is how much how much we can
lift once again this is probably the
most important step this is our mass of
helium in terms of cubic meters and this
is how much how many kilograms we can
lift per cubic meter so you multiply
those two we get the in kilograms how
much mass we can lift so now let's
subtract out the things that we need to
lift we need to subtract out the mass of
the actual blimp the actual structure
that is holding the helium so let's
subtract that so let's subtract 2.1 one
times 10 to the 5th kilograms and so
after lifting the blimp what do we have
left over well let's see 2.2 and maybe I
should well let me make it 2 point 2
minus 2 point 1 1 we might be able do
that in our heads that's the same thing
as 2 point 2 0 minus 2 point 1 1 20
minus 11 is 9 so we could think of it
that way it's 0.09 or if you want you
could say well 0 minus 1 well let's do a
little bit of regrouping here 10 minus 1
is 9 1 minus 1 is 0 2 minus 2 is 0 so
this gives us this gives us 0 point 0 9
kilograms of lifting capacity after
we've netted out the mass of the blimp
after netting out the mass of the blimp
oh actually let me be careful 0.09 times
10 to the 5th times 10 to the 5th
kilograms that we can lift after netting
out the
of the blimp this is what we can use to
lift the people and their luggage with
so they tell us that the people and
luggage that each person plus that
person's luggage is 10 to the 2nd
kilograms so let's divide this by 10 to
the 2nd divided by 10 to the 2nd and we
could I guess we could say kilograms per
person kilograms per person and then
what do we end up with well this is
going to be equal to 10 to the 5th
divided by 10 squared is going to be 10
to the 3rd so that's going to be this is
going to simplify to 10 to the 3rd so we
get 0.09 times 10 to the third and then
kilograms divided by kilograms per
person if we just think about the
dimensional analysis this is the same
thing as kilograms times the reciprocal
of this of people of person persons or
person per kilogram kilogram gets
cancelled out and you're just left with
people or persons so this is how many
people when we say people were saying
the people plus their luggage so what is
0.09 times 10 to the third well that's
just this times that's 0.09 times 1,000
so let's multiply it if we start with
0.09 we multiply it by 10 once we get to
0.9 multiply it by 10 again we get to 9
multiply it by 10 again we get to 90 so
this right over here is the same thing
as 90 people so we can lift we can the
maximum load for this blimp is 990
people and their luggage